moving on former defense secretary
General James Madison studio 57 for his
first live interview since resigning
from the Trump administration his new
book is titled callsign chaos learning
to lead in it general mattis writes I
did as well as I could for as long as I
could when my concrete solutions and
strategic advice especially keeping
faith with our allies no longer
resonated it was time to resign Journal
mattis served as Secretary of Defense
for nearly two years during his long
career in the Marine Corps before his
service as defense secretary he held key
roles leading troops involved in the
wars in Iraq and Afghanistan general
good morning it's good to see you
you served almost two years I know you
expected to serve for how is this
unexpected summer going it's going
wonderfully west of the Rockies tell me
I'm enjoying life thing I don't want
just Washington I I miss the people in
Washington I don't miss any of the
issues Anthony
not one bit you told our David Martin
that the pullout from Syria announced
pullout by President Trump of troops
from Syria weighed heavily in your
decision to resign how did you know that
it was time not only on watching that
issue has reversed itself troops are now
remaining in Syria so I'm curious do you
wish you could reverse yourself and go
back no I decisions I don't have regrets
about them I've always believed strongly
that America needs allies I stand on
that because my formative experiences
were that whenever we were in trouble we
had allies with us and I wanted the
president to have someone more aligned
with his views so I I needed to leave it
what do you think the president got
wrong about Syria well I think when you
leave an administration over policy
matters and I laid that out in the
letter when I noted the need for allies
and all I think you all a period of
silence afterwards we have a million
troops around the world who are trying
to defend this experiment we call
America I don't believe that
administration officials should should
leave the administration and then start
creating controversy with comments
outside when they
they owe a period of Ivan call it a duty
of silence long enough for the Secretary
of State the president secretary of
defense to protect the country if not
controversial excuse me if not
controversy maybe compliments this is a
book about leadership and a good book at
that what would you say is your favorite
leadership quality of the sitting
president well I think we started right
in the book Bing West my co-author and I
in 2013 we were on version 5 in 2017
when I was called to join the
administration and it's not a book about
the sitting president so I'd prefer to
stay firmly focused on what good
leadership is like I I'd lead 40 sailors
and Marines in an infantry platoon I'd
led 250,000 soldiers sailors airmen
Marines Coast Guardsmen Allied troops
later you learn a lot about yourself you
learn a lot about leadership when you go
through that and I wanted to pass this
on when and why did you decide to
include your time with the Trump
administration into this book like you
said you've been writing this for five
years yes what I did Maria Elena was I
put into the prologue why the book had
been delayed for two years coming out
why it was coming out at this time and
my view is that government service is a
privilege it's also a duty I was brought
up that way and when any president
Republican or Democrat asks you to do
something as long as you're prepared to
do it you just roll up your sleeves and
your work you don't get into you know
wringing their hands and wondering about
it just pitch in and do the best you can
to help support the governance of the
country resignation later it's in that
book and it's been made public did was
it your decision to leave or were you
fired
were you pushed into resigning or
pressured into his thing it was
completely my decision to leave I had I
believe a good relationship with the
president I've read some of the stories
that we didn't have a good relationship
it was very forthright I would have time
with the president weekly over lunch
private lunch or in his office the
president knew everything I was doing
and I understood what the president
wanted done there just came a point
where I thought he needed a different
Secretary of Defense the president the
the day before you resigned last
December the president on Twitter said
we have won against Isis secretary
Pompeo was here a couple weeks ago and
he said in some places now Isis is more
powerful than it was three or four years
ago what do you think has happened the
challenge we face today is that
terrorism is an ambient threat it's
simply out there it's going to be there
on 9/11 we were reminded of that right
here in this town when over 3,000
innocent people were murdered I think
secretary Pompeo has it right and I
would leave those who are in the
administration now to speak to the
threat secretary of homeland security
secretary McAlinden told Anthony Mason
not long ago that the biggest threat
internally is white extremism white
supremacist extremism would you say that
there needs to be a reprioritizing of
defense money toward that threat here at
home I don't give policy advice from
what I call the cheap seats outside the
people in those seats right now have
that response rate however I would agree
that divisive nough since ID this
country is probably the biggest threat
the lack of respect the lack of
listening to one another and accepting
that even people who disagree with this
may be right once in a while you think
the president can heal that divisive
miss well I think that this is not about
one person or one administration this
goes back a while and it's time for all
at least the majority of us to roll up
our sleeves and get to work what's
printed on the coin that every one of us
had in our pocket the pluralist unum out
of many one there are many areas where I
think we have agreement we're no longer
talking about those and we need to talk
about common and ground as much as we
need to talk about where we disagree and
when you talk about this internal
divisive 'no set is the biggest threat
to our democracy are you talking about
congress or you're talking about the
politicians being divided are you
talking about the country being divided
what do you think it's a biggest threat
to our democracy Elena I think it's all
of those
I believe what has happened is when we
run elections it's always about dividing
I'm smart you're not I'm I'm wise and
you're you're dumb it's not always
pretty it's not always civil well
welcome to democracy you once the
elections over you go into governance
and it's not about divisive niche it's
about unity at that but we no longer
seem to go to governance which like
we're in a constant election mode and
constantly finding fault reason to cheer
against each other instead of working
together in the military you could not
win on the battlefield in a corporation
you could not win in the business place
with that sort of divisive miss inside
general mattis thank you so much for
being with us this morning callsign
chaos learning to lead goes on sale
tomorrow and